Hey, coming back to this darning critical effect and to your
question, I think in paragliding it's a good thing to fly a lot
and spend a lot of hours. When you when you go into speed
flying or maybe into paragliding when let's say you wouldn't have
to work and this is all you can do and you just do this all the
time. I think then you are much more
likely to get overconfident. It's kind of easy.
It's not so scary both of it. You are close to the ground, you
don't fly too much in turbulence.
I think in speed flying it can be an advantage if you have some
breaks in between a couple of months where you don't fly, you
know, for example, because it's spring and it's very thermic and
then you go back to it and then it feels kind of fast again.
And you were like, oh wow, this shit is fast.
And it stops you a little bit from being overconfident.
And I think as well for BASE jumping.
But if you would go and speed fly every day, then this would
start to feel very normal. And when it feels too normal, it
becomes dangerous. And maybe it's a little bit the
same if park hiding because you're fast, it's easy and you
start to lose maybe the respect of it.
And then obviously it becomes dangerous.
And when it comes to flying cross country thermallying that
always includes turbulence. And turbulence is scary and we
all have fear up there sometimes and some acknowledge that and
some say they're never scared, which I never believe.
But maybe that turbulence, that fear it, you know, like helps to
not become overconfident as much as you do with speed flying or
product ID. And I'm sure it's kind of
similar with Aqua Flying. It's a very interesting topic
because practice makes a man perfect kind of a thing or a
woman as well. No discrimination but is usually
the key and but taking breaks because too much of anything is
bad. I completely agree, but like you
can get stuck in your head or be it whatever, overtraining is a
very real thing and systematic fatigue sets in.
Accumulative fatigue is is also a real performance rater.
So if one can be aware of this. But I think this is where I can
ask heli to come in on the closing comments.
Heli coming in on stalls or anything like that.
Is there a sweet number of stalls that a person can do or
going above or below that number can be counterproductive or
extra productive that you that you have seen from your ears of
SIV training? I'm not sure if there's a sweet
number. The amount of stalls, let's say
100 full stalls on a wing will make you feel.
I wanna say there's an amount of numbers what you should do, like
a friend of mine, like somebody say one time, do it until you do
it. You like to do it.
It's not like that. You can go out there with lake.
And so you want super scared of it that you can get out there
and say, OK, now let's stall it with a good feeling.
And it's not to do the full stall, it's the stall point
again. And so some people get this
feeling maybe about overconfidence, OK, too early
and say now I know how to do it. But if we got stomach feeling to
do it and I cannot say to 101,000 or whatever, I think
there are some people that can do 10,000 that would not learn
it. It looks like if you in the same
curve, what we talked before, I get a lot of people like coming
to me and say, Hey, heli, I want to learn heli.
It's not. And I'm sorry, but I went this,
this struggling with the parachuta and then I left that
learn stalls again, change the mindset of it.
And automatically they end up in the parachute.
And then the step to start spinning the helico is just a
small point so they can train 100 more stalls like they did.
They will not come further. There will be no effort.
And so as well as to start thinking, what can I change to
make it better? The same.
Now I know it, there's a no, it doesn't work.
OK, let's go again to understand what I'm doing.
And as soon you start to try to get better, you're still in the
stone, so there's no number. Guys, closing comments, if you
have to make safety a habit, some baseline things that you
should inculcate in your flying before we call it a day.
I still think for me the choice of wing is one of the most
important. The choice of the wing class
when it comes to cross country flying is one of the most
important things for your safety and if you know you can step up
or not, it's pretty simple. As long as you have collapses,
just don't step up. Once you manage to fly 200
kilometres in a single day without collapses, maybe then
you can step up. If you follow that rule, I think
people will be a lot safer. That's such a good explanation.
Our yeah, 200 OK, not collapsing on the same wing and still
pushing the bar up to a point that you are able to go 200 in
one. So it's quite a skill which will
keep you safe on the next generation.
Heli. Your thoughts before we call it
today? If you have no collapses anymore
and you can use your potential, you can fly your wing on speed
bar. You can use the full potential
of the wing. That's the right time to step up
as long as you're struggling to on your low B wing to fly more
than four hours. You don't have to step up on the
E wing on the high B1 on. Another maybe another thought is
like, what do you want to step up even more?
Like the other day I flew with my C note and I was so tired.
It was so demanding. And I know this how being a 5,
it's so easy. I'm like why do I do this to
myself? For this 5% more performance?
I take 3 times more risk. I make it 10 times more
stressful. Is that worth it?
Do I have one thing? I'm not sure.
I think you you mentioned it pretty well that step up based
on your ability and not based on your dreams and and the pre show
notes that we were exchanging. So your dreams will make you
towards a lot of decisions. But to be honest with yourself,
and this is almost impossible to sum up our two hour gem of a
conversation. But if I have to take away, if I
have to talk about some take away.
Just fear is a good thing if it's healthy.
Gives you a lot of intuition which you should listen to based
on which your decision making should look like.
Social pressure on group dynamics will exists at any
given pilot's career stage or take off, be it pushing full WAR
in a gaggle full of triple CS, or be it launching your first
few flights on a hill full of beginner pilots.
That is not going to change. So that means the Dunning Kruger
effect where you go into the peak of ignorance, which I know
everything, then to a value of despair, I don't know nothing
and slope enlightenment to true expert knowledge will come and
go in your life. That is part of being a human
pilot and just try and identify healthy versus unhealthy
confidence signs. There are enough emotional and
psychological triggers that give you the headlines.
And I think a little bit of coaches or instructors
responsibility also lies on how to balance the expectations from
the student where they can stretch them to push their
limits, but also teach them to know their limits when they're
by themselves. And then just figure out tools
for building mental training, which is helpful in either
coming back to the sport or walking away from the sport if
shit hits the fan one day. Because eventually
communication, commitment and clarity and honesty will decide
how you take the take to the skies when you want to.
That's about it, all right. Happy flying everyone.
I'll. Be flying everyone.
Thank you guys. This was longer than expected
but I think holy freaking lolly, this has to be one of the most
informative and unfiltered episodes we have had on the show
and you guys have been the most loved guests and that's why I
decided to bring you both together.
I guess I was like repeat lessons were just reaching
skyrocket rocketing numbers on your solo episodes and I was
like, you know what? It's about time we create some
awesomeness together. From my heart, you guys.
Thank you.